so two weeks ago
i searched the word nationalist on
twitter the results were quite colorful
with expressions like emboldened racist
white supremacist idiot fascist
suck puppets orwillian hitlerian
terrifying i then searched the word
globalist
and got things like socialist sellouts
disgusting corporate propaganda elitist
financial overlords
rootless cosmopolitan rats
even by social media standards the words
are cruel and disgusting
but they reflect the intensity of one of
the most fundamental questions
of our times nationalism or globalism
what is the best path forward this
question impacts everything we care
about
our cultural identity our prosperity
our political systems uh everything the
health of our planet
everything so on the one hand we have
nationalism
collins defines it as a devotion to
one's nation
but also a doctrine that puts national
interests above international
considerations
for nationalists our modern societies
are are built on national grounds
we share a land a history a culture
and we defend each other in a big and
chaotic world
they see nationalism as the only
sensible way to maintain social
stability
but alarmed globalists warn us
self-centered nationalism
can easily turn ugly we've seen it with
20th century fascisms
bloody wars millions of deaths
immeasurable destructions
on the other hand we have globalism the
oxford living dictionary defines it as
the operation or planning
of economic and foreign policy on a
global basis
for nationalists globalism is rapidly
deconstructing what our ancestors took
decades to build it's like spinning on
our soldier storms
it's eroding our national solidarities
and opening the doors to foreign
invasions
but globalists make the case that
reinforcing our global governance
is the only way to tackle big
supranational problems
like nuclear nuclear proliferation the
global refugee crisis
climate change or terrorism or even the
consequences of superhuman
ai so we are at the crossroads
and we are asked to choose nationalism
or globalism
having lived in four continents i've
always been interested in this question
but it took a whole new level when i saw
this happening
the biggest surge in nationalist votes
in western democracies
since world war ii all of a sudden
this isn't theory anymore i mean these
political movements
have built their success with ideas that
could mean down the road losing my
french citizenship
because i'm north african or not being
able to come back home to the us
because i come from a muslim majority
country
you know when you live in a democracy
you live with this idea that
your government will always protect you
as long as you abide by the laws
with the rise of national populism
despite being the best citizen i can
i now have to live with the idea that my
government can hurt me
for reason i cannot control it's very
unsettling
but it forced me to rethink and rethink
this question and try to think deeper
and the more i thought about it the more
i started questioning the question
why would we have to choose between
nationalism and globalism
between loving our country and caring
for the world
there's no reason for that we don't have
to choose between family and country
or region or religion and country we
already have multiple identities and we
leave them
we live with them very well why would we
have to choose between country
and world what if instead of accepting
this absurd choice
we took it on ourselves to fight this
dangerous
binary thinking so for all the
globalists in the in
in the audience i want to ask when i say
the word nationalist
what image comes to your mind something
like this
believe me i think of that too but i'd
like you to remember
that for most people nationalism feels
more like this
or maybe like that you know it's that
thing inside you when you
you know accidentally watch an obscure
olympic sport on tv
wait and the mere sight of an unknown
athlete wearing your national colors
gets you all excited you know your
heartbeat goes up your
your stress level goes up and you're
standing in front of that tv
and screaming with passion for that
athlete to win
that's nationalism it's people happy to
be together happy to belong to a large
national community why would it be wrong
you know globalist you may think of
nationalism as an old 19th century idea
that is destined to fade but i'm sorry
to tell you that the facts
are not on your side when the world
value survey asked more than 89 000
people
across 60 countries how proud they felt
about their country
88.5 said very proud or quite proud
88.5 nationalism is not going away
anytime soon
it's a it's a powerful feeling that
according to another study
is a strong predictor of individual
happiness
it's crazy but your happiness is more
correlated
with national satisfaction than we think
you would expect
like household income or your job
satisfaction
or your health satisfaction so if
nationalism makes people happy
why would anybody take it away from them
fellow globalist if if you are like me
you may be attached to globalization for
humanistic reasons
and you may take great joy in some of
its accomplishments since 1945.
after all major regions of the world
have been exceptionally peaceful
extreme poverty rates around the globe
are trending down
and more than 2 billion people most
notably in asia
so spectacular improvements in their
standards of living
but studies also show that globalization
has a dark side
and left on the side of the road
hundreds of millions of people
on western middle classes with anemic
income growth for more than two decades
possibly three decades according to some
studies
we cannot ignore this elephant in our
room if anything our collective energy
would be better used finding ways to
fix this aspect of globalization instead
of
you know fighting this polarizing battle
against nationalism
so now the nationalists in the in the
audience i have some
crusty non-binary nuggets for you
when i say the word globalist what comes
to your mind
uh out of touch one percent plutocrats
or maybe the heartless greedy wall
street type right
or maybe people like me with multiple
origins living in a big cosmopolitan
metropolis well you remember that world
value survey that i mentioned earlier
it showed another fascinating finding 71
percent of the world population
agreed with the statement i'm a citizen
of the world
do you know what it means most of us are
simultaneously proud of our country
and citizens of the world and it gets
even better
the citizens of the world in the survey
show higher level of national pride
than the ones that rejected that label
so once and for all being a globalist
doesn't mean betraying your country
it just means that you have enough
social empathy and you project some of
it outside your national borders
now i know that when i dig into my own
nationalist feelings
one of my anxieties versus the
globalized world
is is national identity how are we going
to preserve
what makes us special what makes us
different what brings us together and as
i started thinking about it i realized
something really strange
which is that a lot of the key
ingredients of our national identities
actually come from outside our national
borders
like think of the letters that we use
every day i don't know if you
realize but the the uh latin script the
latin alphabet that we use
has its origins thousands of years ago
near the nile river
it all started with with a cow just like
this
that was captured by a scribe into an
elegant hieroglyph
that hieroglyph was transcribed by a
semite in the sinai
into the letter alif alef traveled
with phoenicians and reached the
european shores
in greece where it became alpha the
mother of our letter a
so that's how an egyptian cow became our
letter a
and same thing with the egyptian house
that became
bait beta and b and the egyptian fish
dalet delta and e
our most fundamental texts are full of
egyptian cows houses
and fish and
there are so many other examples like
take the united kingdom
and its monarchy queen elizabeth ii
german ancestry the mottos on the royal
coat of arms
all written in french not a single word
of english
take france and it's you know and it's
iconic eiffel tower
the inspiration the united states of
america
and i don't mean las vegas i mean 19th
century new york
this was the tallest building in new
york in the mid 19th century does it
remind you of something
and and you may think of china as a
self-contained civilization
protected behind its great war but think
twice
the chinese official ideology marxism
made in germany uh one of china's
biggest religion
buddhism imported from india india's
favorite pastime cricket uh
i really love this quote from ashish
nandi who said cricket is an indian game
accidentally discovered by the british
so you know these are good reminders
that
a lot of what we love in our national
traditions actually come from previous
waves of globalization
and beyond individual symbols there are
whole national traditions
that could not have existed without
globalization
and the example that comes to my mind is
a world beloved national tradition
italian cuisine my friends if you ever
have a chance to go to a super authentic
italian restaurant
that only serves ancient roman recipes
my advice for you is
don't go you'd get very very
disappointed
no no spaghetti no pasta that really
started in in sicily
in the 8th century when it was under
arabian rule
no perfect espresso no creamy cappuccino
that came from abyssinia by yemen
in the 17th century and of course no
perfect pizza napolitana how would you
make it without
the tomatoes of the new world no instead
you would be served probably a lot of
porridge some vegetable mostly
cabbage some cheese and maybe if you're
lucky
the absolute delicacy of that time
perfectly cooked flattened dorm ice
thankfully it was not a close tradition
preserved by fanatic watchdogs
now it was an open process nourished by
explorers
traders street sellers and innovative
home cooks
and in many ways globalization is a
chance for our national traditions
to be questioned regenerated
reinterpreted to attract new converts
to stay vibrant and relevant over time
so just remember this
most of us nationalists in the world are
globalists and most of us globalists in
the world
are nationalists a lot of what we like
in our national traditions
come from outside our national borders
and the reason we venture outside our
national borders
is to discover these other national
traditions so the real question should
not be to choose between nationalism
and globalism the real question is how
can we do both
better it's a complex question for a
complex world
that calls for creative non-binary
solutions
what are you waiting for thank you
you